muy buenos días este año 2019 estamos de
fiesta celebramos el 50 aniversario de
la llegada del hombre a la luna con la
misión apolo 11 el 21 de julio de 1969
después de cinco días de trepidante
viaje
neil amstrong abrió la escotilla de su
módulo lunar descendió lentamente la
escalerilla y se dispuso a pisar la
superficie de nuestro satélite natural
por primera vez en la historia
[Música]
se estima que más de 100 millones de
personas vieron en directo estás
icónicas imágenes en todo el mundo y
aguantaron la respiración hasta escuchar
la ya famosa frase de un pequeño paso
para un hombre un gran salto para la
humanidad y lo más increíble de esto es
que hacía solo 12 años que la unión
soviética había lanzado el primer
satélite artificial de la historia eso
quiere decir que en poco más de una
década se había desarrollado toda la
tecnología necesaria para que tres
personas pudieran salir al frío y hostil
espacio exterior viajar cuatrocientos
mil kilómetros y llegar a la superficie
terrestre pasear y volver a casa sanos y
salvos
y después yo estoy segurísimo que si
hubiéramos preguntado a ingenieros
espaciales de esa época
muchísimos habrían jurado o habrían
apostado a que en 10-15 años estarían
pisando marte el ser humano estaría en
marte sin embargo esto no fue así la
realidad es que desde el final de las
misiones apolo en 1972 el ser humano lo
más lejos que ha ido de la tierra es a
la órbita baja concretamente a la
estación espacial internacional que es
un laboratorio que orbita la tierra a
muy poca altura con astronautas dentro
qué pasó
pues el resumen está en esta imagen de
aquí el pasado y el presente el pasado
la luna en el año 69 con la tecnología
de entonces fuimos capaces de recorrer
400 mil kilómetros que es lo mismo que
dar 60 vueltas a nuestro planeta y
volver en la actualidad con la
tecnología que tenemos con la tecnología
que tenemos ahora solo somos capaces de
subir a 400 kilómetros menos de lo que
separa barcelona y madrid para entender
por qué de ese gran retroceso y también
cuál es la perspectiva de la exploración
espacial en el futuro voy a presentar
esta charla la historia empieza en el
año 1945 la segunda guerra mundial está
acabando los aliados han ganado y los
eeuu por un lado la unión soviética por
el otro se dan mucha prisa para intentar
conseguir hacerse con muchos de los
avances militares de la alemania nazi
entre dichas armas hay una súper
importante
el cohete v2
el cohete v2 es un misil
de largo alcance balístico es el primer
gran misil de la historia capaz de
cargar 1000 kilogramos de explosivos a
300 kilómetros de distancia el misil v2
fue responsable de más de 7000 muertes
principalmente en la ciudad de londres
los eeuu por un lado la unión soviética
por el otro consiguen varios ejemplares
de este misil consiguen varias piezas se
disponen a estudiarlo exhaustivamente
también les interesa mucho conseguir
reclutar a los ingenieros y a los
científicos que han desarrollado estas
armas y así es como werner von braun
tenemos en la imagen termina en eeuu
trabajando para el ejército
norteamericano a cambio claro de un
bonito visado y de un poco de amnesia
generalizada sobre consumir sobre su
vinculación con los nazis estamos en el
inicio de la guerra fría y los dos
bloques empiezan a desarrollar sus
propios misiles para apuntar hacia el
otro pero lo interesante es que esta
nueva arma también tiene otra aplicación
si en vez de un sitio apuntar al
enemigo se apunta al espacio
tienes la capacidad de poner en órbita
satélites
sondas incluso naves tripuladas así la
guerra fría se extiende al espacio ya
esta competición le llamamos la carrera
espacial en un primer momento la unión
soviética se lo toma mucho más en serio
y el 4 de octubre de 1957 mandan el
primer satélite artificial de la
historia el sputnik responde que se le
reconoce por su sonido
[Música]
este big beep era simplemente una manera
que tenían de decir estoy pasando por
encima de vuestra cabeza y pensad como
siento eso en la población de los
estados unidos
de repente cualquiera podía sintonizar y
escuchar ese bip que quería decir que lo
que ellos llamaban una luna soviética
estaba pasando por encima ante esta
situación el presidente de esa época y
sen hauer reunió a varios asesores para
ver qué podían hacer el asesor
científico dijo estaba muy emocionado y
dijo esto es increíble ahora mismo los
soviéticos tienen la capacidad de ir al
espacio y hacer experimentos para
entender cómo es el entorno en el
espacio saber por ejemplo pues la
densidad de la poca atmósfera que habrá
ahí o saber por ejemplo la temperatura o
el nivel de radiación digamos que usáis
en hauer pues no le interesó mucho era
un hombre más de armas que de ciencia
pero el asesor militar dijo sí sí eso es
cierto pero además lo que quiere decir
es que ahora la unión soviética podría
poner muchísimas bombas nucleares en
órbita y entonces siempre tendríamos
varias pasando por encima del territorio
estadounidense y si las lanzarán en los
pocos minutos que tardarían en caer
no podríamos reaccionar por lo cual
ahora mismo la unión soviética tendría
la capacidad de devastar totalmente
nuestro país en pocos minutos para eso
sí que ya me parece un poco más
importante a ese jaguar de manera que
dijo él y su administración hay que
intentar ganar el terreno perdido y se
empezaron a poner recursos se crea la
nasa se coge a werner von braun el
diseñador del v2 y se le pone a trabajar
no en hacer misiles sino en hacer
lanzadores espaciales que hay que
decirlo es lo que él siempre había
querido hacer y se desarrolla también la
agencia digamos de desarrollo
tecnológico espacial militar que la
mayoría de la gente no conoce se llama
darpa pero que en realidad son los que
tienen el dinero de los cachivaches de
ciencia ficción
pero eso es así
y qué sucede entonces lo que sucede
es que
eeuu intenta recuperar el terreno
perdido pero lleva mucha desventaja de
manera que la unión soviética son
primeros por ejemplo en lanzar un perro
al espacio pobre laica son primeros en
lanzar un hombre a poner un hombre en
órbita yuri gagarín son primeros por
ejemplo en hacer un paseo espacial en
salir del módulo y pasar por el espacio
son primeros en poner una mujer en
órbita valentina tereshkova como
anécdota de cómo estaba la situación en
esa época me encanta hablar de este
bonito perro
en esa época ya estaban en la casa
blanca el matrimonio kennedy y resulta
que un día recibieron un regalo este
cachorro junto al regalo había una carta
del mismísimo presidente de la unión
soviética nikita kruschov les decía como
nos gustan mucho los perros aquí tenéis
un regalo un perro soviético de pura
raza final de la carta como anécdota
ponía por cierto esta perra es hija de
una perra del espacio una perra que fue
al espacio y volvió sin un solo rasguño
disfrutarla lógicamente eso era un
bofetón en toda la cara eso y todo lo
que estaba sucediendo de manera que
kennedy en 1962 hace un famoso discurso
en el que compromete a toda la nación
para un objetivo común
[Música]
el compromiso es clarísimo se
comprometen a poner un hombre en la luna
antes de que acabe la década esto
parecía absolutamente imposible pero lo
interesante sobre todo viniendo de un
político es que no se quedó sólo en
palabras también pusieron los recursos
necesarios en forma de instalaciones en
forma de
y económica en forma de recursos humanos
para lograrlo todo el país
empujó esta empresa y realmente como
sabéis lo lograron antes de que acabara
la década neil amstrong la misión apolo
11 pisa la luna y este en realidad es el
final de la carrera espacial
los eeuu ganan a mí me gusta siempre
reivindicar el programa espacial
soviético quedó empañado totalmente por
esta victoria que efectivamente fue una
victoria por ko pero la realidad es que
hasta ese momento el programa soviético
estaba ganando por los puntos de calle
lo habían hecho casi todo antes después
de esta misión apolo 11 mucha gente cree
que ya no volvimos a la luna me lo
pregunta mucha gente ahora es que sólo
fuimos una vez en realidad no es cierto
hubo varias misiones más que fueron a la
luna en realidad hasta la misión apolo
17 un total de 12 personas pisaron la
superficie
lo que pasó realmente es que en el
momento en el que se gana la carrera
espacial esa gran inversión en recursos
deja de tener sentido ya se ha logrado
el objetivo se ha ganado por tanto en
ese momento se corta muchísimo los
fondos se deja en ese preciso instante
se decide que se deja de fabricar el
cohete saturno 5 un monstruoso cohete
que es el que nos llevó a la luna que
por cierto fue diseñado de nuevo por
werner von braun de manera que las
siguientes misiones hasta la polo 17 van
ya por inercia pero digamos que el
interés se ha acabado y la realidad
espero que haya quedado clara nos fuimos
a la luna por entender cómo era nos
fuimos a la luna por ciencia nos fuimos
a la luna por conocimiento la razón fue
política
militar propaganda
a partir de ese momento lo que sucedió
se entiende bastante bien con esta
gráfica siento poner una gráfica no es
una clase pero se entiende muy
fácilmente es simplemente la evolución
del presupuesto de la nasa a lo largo de
su historia se puede ver que en un
inicio tiene un incremento absolutamente
brutal y que alrededor del punto álgido
de la carrera espacial alrededor del año
1965 llegó el presupuesto de la nasa a
significar casi el 45 por ciento del
presupuesto total de los eeuu
eso es una cantidad inagotable casi de
dinero después como podéis ver que hay
en picado y a partir de 1975 siempre ha
estado por debajo del 1% actualmente es
del 0.5 por ciento
con esa realidad los años 70 80 90 y en
la actualidad la manera de explorar el
espacio cambia totalmente ya no mandamos
personas mandamos sondas no tripuladas
es mucho más barato y mucho más sencillo
mandar robots que mandar personas de
esta manera lo que hemos estado haciendo
durante estas décadas es por ejemplo
explorar los límites exteriores del
sistema solar conocer júpiter conocer
saturno hemos puesto mucho empeño en
mandar muchos tipos de robots diferentes
a marte también se han creado diferentes
agencias espaciales la agencia espacial
europea la agencia espacial china y a
partir de 1998 se empezó a construir la
estación espacial internacional nuestra
casa en el espacio todo eso es
espectacular no digo que no las misiones
son increíbles resultados súper buenos y
para el presupuesto que había
probablemente no se podría hacer más
pero yo creo que se debería haber hecho
más
creo sinceramente que estamos destinados
a salir de este planeta creo que estamos
destinados a ser una especie multi
planetaria
el ser humano es un animal curioso por
naturaleza necesitamos saber qué hay
detrás de esa montaña que hay debajo del
océano que hay en un planeta más allá y
esa curiosidad está innata en nuestro
adn y forma parte de hecho de nuestro
éxito biológico y es precisamente esta
curiosidad la que hace que mucha gente
como yo pongamos nuestro granito de
arena cada día en nuestro trabajo
soñando por ejemplo que algún día la
luna pues estará habitada por gente y
será vista desde la tierra pues como un
continente más el séptimo continente en
la luna gente trabajando gente viviendo
o por ejemplo yo sueño con que mi hijo
algún día me dirá papá me voy de
vacaciones a marte a la aventura
ya sé que eso suena a ciencia ficción
pero en realidad no lo es no estamos tan
lejos solo hace faltan dos cosas
recursos y recuperar un poco ese
espíritu aventurero que tuvimos hace
décadas
por si algunos estos parece muy
idealista muy soñador tengo también
razones prácticas
por ejemplo económica está demostrado
que la exploración espacial revierte en
la sociedad por cada euro que gastamos
en la exploración espacial más de diez
euros retornan en forma de tecnología en
forma de eventos en forma de
conocimiento hay otra razón también muy
poderosa si queremos perpetuar el hombre
en el universo necesitamos salir de este
planeta la tierra es frágil y hay
múltiples razones por las que algún día
puede dejar de ser habitable el impacto
de un gran asteroide el propio cambio
climático si permanecemos en la tierra
somos tremendamente vulnerables y todo
esto lo resumiría en una frase que me
encanta de un pionero de la ciencia que
vivió en rusia hace 100 años
konstantín tsiolkovski él dijo la tierra
es la cuna de la humanidad pero nadie
puede vivir para siempre en su cuna
en el presente por suerte están
cambiando las cosas hay un nuevo
paradigma al que llamamos espacio 2.0
básicamente están saliendo por primera
vez empresas privadas que empujan mucho
hay empresas por ejemplo que quieren
llevar turistas al espacio y lo harán
pronto hay empresas que pretenden
explotar minería en asteroides la
empresa spacex de lo más que está
empezando ahora el desarrollo de un
gigantesco cohete y de una nave espacial
que se llama starship
que será la que llevará en las próximas
décadas a decenas de personas a marte
junto estas empresas hay nuevas agencias
espaciales como la china que están
haciendo las cosas muy muy bien y todo
este grupo de nueva fuerza que está
saliendo está haciendo que eeuu que
europa que rusia se ve obligada a
despertar de su letargo
no es de extrañar por ejemplo que la
semana pasada la administración
estadounidense anunciara bombo y
platillo que quiere volver a ir a la
luna que quiere llevar astronautas tan
pronto como en 2024
el discurso se parece un poquito al de
kennedy que acabamos de ver la
diferencia es que en ese momento como he
comentado aparte del discurso se
pusieron los medios ahora lo dudo tiene
más pinta de propaganda que de otra cosa
pero no pasa nada porque en realidad no
van a ser los eeuu la nasa no va a ser
una empresa privada a la que nos va a
llevar a colonizar otros mundos esto va
a ser una apuesta planetaria muchas
agencias muchas empresas trabajando
juntas pero para que eso suceda
necesitamos que todos nosotros la
sociedad lo veamos importante y
presionemos para que esté en la agenda
de los políticos de los inversores
se dice que la primera persona que va a
pisar marte ya ha nacido yo también lo
creo de hecho podría ser que estuviera
viendo esta charla por eso os voy a
hacer una oferta
se buscan candidatos para viaje
peligroso sueldo escaso frío extremo
largos meses de completa oscuridad
peligro constante no se asegura el
regreso honor y reconocimientos en caso
de éxito
yo no sé si alguien se apuntaría porque
realmente parece un anuncio para
encontrar el grupo de astronautas que ir
a marte por primera vez sin embargo esto
es de principios del siglo 20
es simplemente ernest shackleton
buscando tripulación para su viaje a la
antártida
lo más interesante es que se presentaron
más de 5000 personas
cinco mil personas dispuestas a perderlo
todo arriesgarlo todo por aumentar las
fronteras y el conocimiento del ser
humano
muy pronto estaremos en el mismo punto y
lo hemos estado muchas veces justo antes
de las misiones apolo
necesitaremos a gente soñadora
con ganas de dar un paso hacia adelante
se aceptan candidatos
[Aplausos]